Stanley Cup championship drive words I
never thought I'd say into a microphone
words I bet Jon Hamm never thought what
ever cross his mind but he's joining us
right now in there doesn't show oh yeah
John never don't never don't believe fun
fact YES on Gloria came out in 1982 the
same year the Cardinals won the World
Series I mean worlds are colliding rich
did Laura Branigan and Whitey Herzog
ever have like a Yalta like summit John
do you think they must have it's clear
Darrell Porter was there there was just
a whole situation Willie McGee moderated
you know what man it's amazing how
things work out in the world what are
you feeling right now let's go what's
coursing through your veins Jon Hamm
well I was I was unfortunately I mean
look I you know life intervenes and all
of these wonderful sporting times would
have as well but yes I had so I had to I
had to be I was not literally on set I
was shooting and thank God I was
shooting in Canada where every Canadian
person in the world was like um maybe
take a minute yep I'm gonna need one and
so I was I was shooting a commercial up
here for a company called skip the
dishes and free plug and yes and I I
watched it and I was just like my mouth
is on the floor I just I couldn't get
over it and you know I obviously held
out hope and I knew that these guys
throughout the throughout the entire
finals nothing just the final throughout
the playoffs have been so resilient and
coming back after losses were just nuts
so I I had hope and then I win and when
I watched the first you know 20 minutes
I thought oh we're done there's no way I
thought John I thought the same thing -
the Blues looked slower they looked like
they were nothing was crisp at all and
the Bruins were just dominating but man
Bennington was he he got you through
that first period and then it Benton was
like out of men in black I mean also
free plug yes
he was like he had two extra arms he had
like legs that had like go-go-gadget
extensions and he kept us in the game
which he's done for the last you know
six months of the year and he just was
on another level and you know what
happened was I think I'm not going to
speak for the Boston crowd but I think
the same thing happened to Boston that
happened to us in in games 3 & 6 the
emotion got a little over you know on
over the top of those guys and like you
do they kind of I think they kind of
gassed out and when we scored that first
goal and a second goal in the first
period I think that that was just like a
you know just a you know this blue it
just blew him up and they and they had
nothing left and it was you know it's a
long series it's a long playoffs and I
just couldn't get over the fact that
they came they came and they and they
they closed out and the way they did
yeah man I mean like again that first
period one shot on goal 27 seconds in
and then about 15 minutes later another
shot on goal and then the third one
lights the lamp with eight seconds to go
in the period another lit lamp and I
just was sitting there I'm like hockey
is what a fickle Beast this board well
you can never say you know Rask who had
been lights out
all series goes into the second period
with a stat line of four shots against
and two saves I mean that's that you're
right that's just that's how hockey is
that's the craziest thing about it and I
I've got I've got so much respect for
that team and and how how they play it
especially to kept those guys in in the
in the series and in the same way that
Bennington did and Chara you know he's
42 years old and comes out and playing
with a broken jaw for three games like
what a beast but I just there's nothing
like our team they just would not be
denied and that and they've been that
way since January 2nd and I think that
all the credit goes to to the guys first
obviously
Binnington obviously for sparking the
team and then the Berube I mean what a
what a what a story the guys has there
been an interim coach that is one
Stanley Cup well I mean if for him to
come in and obviously he knew Bennington
from from the minors and and it all just
you know came together from Berube to
Bingham Bennington to the whole team Jon
Hamm here on the Rich Eisen show so but
some of the stories that left out at me
over the last few weeks that I came to
know and learn and really appreciate and
I know you've you've met and you know
Pat maroon who's from st. Louis walked
me through his story and people through
his story and how you've gotten to know
him or or come across him John
patty maroon Oakville finest he is a is
a lovely guy he is the st. Louis local
the guy the guy who took a you know took
a a shorter deal and a lesser deal to
play at home basically because he wanted
to be near his kid and I got to meet his
his his young son after we we beat the
stars in game seven and when when
they're in scored the the overtime goal
the double overtime goal and you know
it's it's it's just a great story the
guys the guys a hometown hero and you
know you don't get a lot of stories like
that these days
no you don't but uh but Pat is he's a
great guy you know is is uh his is his
kids a little cutie he had a jean jacket
on some little rig it's pretty cool I'd
love it I mean the whole thing dude did
you did you get to meet Layla the you
know I'm sure you knew she made it to
Boston yesterday yeah I star with the
Cubs and I got to meet her after Game
four when when we won in st. Louis and
you know her story is obviously just as
impressive as anything and and the boys
won a
when she came down to the locker room to
say hi and and they they're all just
they're so sweet to her and you know the
that's so inspiring to them obviously
for for for obvious reasons I mean this
this is a this is a little kid and she's
fighting off you know the fight of her
life and and and so it's one of those
deals and they all they'll all say it
they're just like hey if you can do a
weekend and you know it's cheesy and
it's in its and it's corny but man it's
it's real and that that's that's the
kind of thing that that st. Louis
rallies around and it's it's it's
honestly it's sweet and when I saw that
little girl you know whole Easton you
know hosting the cup was with Perea Co
there it was it was you know it's
emotional yeah it is it really is Jon
Hamm here on the Richard show couple
more minutes left with with with him so
again walk me through so you're on set
my trailer yeah okay all right here's
the deal I'll paint it for you please
I'm shooting this commercial the game
starts and I'm like please nobody talk
to me I don't want to hear it I don't
want to like just let me walk let me do
my thing
yes and and I'm walking around and I'm
they have I got it in my trailer and I'm
watching the game and I watched the
first period and I'm like it's not
trending well we're not this is not
happening I don't know what to say
so I go and I we shoot a couple takes of
a thing and then they're there they're
moving cameras and they reset and
they're doing a deal okay okay so I'm
sitting there they're lighting and I'm
sitting there and the first lady goes
good news I said okay good news I like
good news he goes one oh I said okay
good news that's good news good news and
literally three minutes litters like
good news okay
what's that he goes - oh God so now I'm
like okay since I've not been watching
this go to goals so now should I now
watch the rest of the game I don't know
what to freaking out
so basically I miss most of the second
periods because
atishoo and then at a certain point they
come in and say that the first ad goes
he didn't say anything he just puts
three fingers up and I'm like you gotta
be kidding me
and before I know it he puts four
fingers up and I'm like okay well I have
to walk off the stage right now at this
point and I go back to my trailer I
watched the last five minutes and I'm
just losing my mind and so then the
texts start rolling in I get about 250
texts from people around the country
friends and people I've worked with and
people from Boston and everything and
and the best ones I'll be honest were
for my friends from you know growing up
and all that stuff but a close second
was the salty Boston text and rolling in
from people like Bill Simmons and and
the like who who couldn't quite couldn't
quite get their head around the fact
that we won but hadn't deal with it
anyway John how many yachts can they
water-ski behind this is the century I
mean come on I'll be honest when I saw
the thing that Denis Leary did that was
there like hype video where it's like
it's been four months since I've had a
parade I was you know that's the right
attitude I just love it just you know
that's the fan sort of mentality John
that's why you are as pure as the driven
snow is that when you are rooting so
hard and you have to step away you're
not watching and then your team succeeds
you have to sit there and think is it
you know even though it's don't say this
about that because you know there was
apparently because I'm not on Twitter or
any social media or anything there was
apparently a bear I think they call it a
tweet storm that the kids call it when I
showed up at at game six Psalms beard
mm-hmm where everyone's at all well
you've ruined that you've cursed the
team you you've this you've that and I
had to remind my my friends I was like
you know I'm not on the team
I am of the team and when when when Tom
Cruise and the good people of Top Gun
today we need you to shoot there are no
Stanley Cup beards allowed so it was
very funny that people kind of lost
their minds about that and so the I'm
also perfectly glad that we we ended up
winning but uh you know it's it's still
funny how people get wound up about
stuff and I can't get my head around it
right now I'm still I'm still losing my
mind so this is the reason why you
shaved is for Tom Cruise is that what
you're saying John did I just get that
hand
yes it's per Top Gun okay so now
everybody just back off you had to do it
for cruise and your team won so
everybody just back off on the tweet
storming right John right okay so come
with the storming of the tweeting oh man
if it's feasible would you go to the
parade w already looked and seen if this
is a possibility for you book my dick I
booked my ticket I will be going I will
be yelling I will cheering and there
will be hugging there'll be high-fiving
there will be so many celebratory
actions and moments but I don't think I
can catalog all of them but that means
unfortunately I think Richard yes sir
but I will miss you that I will miss
your birthday Oh Jonathan that's just
fine it's all good John you know what I
will accept that as long as you get to
drink from the cup John that's what you
must do have one of those have one of
those guys please do have one of those
guys tip it for you put your favorite
whatever you want in there and just
enjoy it drink sip from the cup jon hamm
Congrats Richard you're the best you are
too so birthday next but less you know
blues play Gloria there it is to play
them out we'll do it live John here on
the Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
TV for free on BR live or download the
Rich Eisen show app